[Music]
[Music]
good evening my name is Ellen Harris and
on behalf of the office of the Arts at
MIT I am happy to welcome you to the
Institute and to our conference the
public patron drafting a mandate for a
federal arts agency the conference is
being presented by the Office of the
Arts and was organized by Mark Tom Green
director of the Council for the Arts at
MIT before tonight's program actually
begins I would like to take this
opportunity to outline briefly the
schedule of events first we hope all of
you here tonight are planning to attend
tomorrow's panel discussions which will
also be held here at Kresge Auditorium
beginning at 9:15 a.m. in the morning
the panel will present and discuss
issues relating to the funding of
creative expression and then after a
break for lunch a second panel will
discuss the role of a federal arts
funding agency in terms of Education in
the arts beginning at 1:30 our panelists
for both discussions comprise an
outstanding roster of artists educators
critics and arts administrators from
across the country all of whom have
faced these issues in their own work at
4:15 following the panel's
representative Louise slaughter chairman
of the Congressional arts caucus will
present the concluding keynote address
after which she will take questions from
the audience
registration for the day's events
including lunch is $35 twenty-five
dollars for students with ID if you
haven't already registered I invite you
to do so following this evenings program
or tomorrow morning here at Kresge's
starting at 8:00 a.m. this evening
Charles M vest president of MIT will
welcome you
after which Senator Edward M Kennedy and
author and art critic Robert Hughes will
present the opening
keynote addresses mr. Hughes has kindly
agreed to accept questions after his
remarks if you wish to ask a question
please step up to one of the floor
microphones in the two center aisles and
when you are recognized please identify
yourself I am sure that it will be
appreciated by all of us if this time is
used for questions only and if you will
keep your questions brief and to the
point I am pleased to announce that the
Office of the Arts at MIT will be
publishing the Proceedings of the
conference the proceedings will be
distributed to all conference
registrants key government officials
members and staff of the congressional
committees involved in the NEA
reauthorization and reappropriation
hearings and arts organizations across
the country MIT will also work towards
developing an interdisciplinary policy
paper to consider models for maintaining
ongoing federal support for the Arts and
Humanities incorporating themes and
insights from our deliberations here
this weekend and now I am pleased to
introduce to you Charles and vest
president of MIT
[Applause]
thank you very much Ellen it's a great
pleasure to welcome all of you to MIT
into this National Conference on the
roles and responsibilities of a federal
art agency in the United States today
now some may see MIT focused as it is on
science and engineering as a rather odd
choice of venue for such a conference
but as most of you already know the arts
are indeed a vital aspect of life here
at the Institute you need only look
around at our outdoor sculptures at our
galleries and when school is in session
at the multitude of courses and programs
and music theater writing photography
dance and film that engage our faculty
our students and our staff one of the
great things about MIT is that this is a
hands-on place we make things here and
much of our learning is through doing I
believe that that is one of the common
denominators of artistic technological
and scientific activity that is one of
the reasons that the arts are indeed
such a vital part of this institution
much of what we do in these fields is
overseen and coordinated by our office
for the Arts which is sponsoring this
conference and a great deal the support
we receive for these programs comes for
the counsel of the Arts at MIT the
volunteer advocacy group of alumni
alumni and Friends that was established
over 20 years ago to foster the Creative
and Performing Arts here at the
Institute so clearly the arts are an
integral part of what we are and what we
do but why is it important for
scientists and engineers to study and
participate in the creative arts quite
simply involvement in the arts broadens
one one's perspective and opens the mind
to new possibilities the arts bring from
and concentrate on the human condition
our history values and cultures the ways
we find inspiration the ways in which we
identify and communicate ideas and
emotions and they help us to see the
world in new ways it's like looking at
an image upside down to see it for what
it is and not for what our eye
are trained to see when we develop our
ability to think creatively we are able
to find new solutions to the problems on
which we are working both in our
laboratories and in our lives creative
activity is creative activity whether it
is the establishment of a new theorem
and abstract mathematics or the
non-obvious optimization of a complex
engineering process or the expression of
an artistic insight education in the
arts is in the sciences helps us to
develop and flex our creative muscle it
is rigorous exercise it is good for us
one of our professors who wonderfully
embodies both of these worlds is Alan
Lightman
the physicist who heads our program and
writing and humanistic studies is the
author of the widely acclaimed acclaimed
novel Einsteins Dreams and in a recent
interview Alan explained this duality of
his interests this way human beings have
this very rational logical need to order
our perception but we also need to take
away the fetters and fly free escape
from the physical world we are both
scientists and artists it is a wonderful
tension we are whole people we can't cut
off one side of ourselves from the other
I cannot think of a better explanation
for why the arts are essential to a
complete education even or perhaps I
should say especially in a place like
MIT science and mathematical literacy
cannot be developed in the absence of
general literacy as Professor Ellen
Harris mi t--'s associate provost for
the Arts who you just met has noted the
arts offer and I quote her a gateway to
improving learning overall by enlarging
the imagination by instilling both
discipline and wonder and by teaching
flexible and creative approaches to
problem-solving in short the sciences
and the arts do and can inform and
reinforce each other so much for the
role of the Arts in education in the
place of the Arts at this institute what
about the role
federal government as a patron of the
Arts what are the principles to be
followed in the goals to be achieved
that is what you are here to discuss and
to debate and if the gods are with us
perhaps even resolve for my part let me
say that when it comes to the role of
government in supporting any aspect of
the academic enterprise I believe that
there is a fundamental principle and
that is that the free investigation of
ideas coupled with merit review by
knowledgeable experts is essential for
maintaining the intellectual and
artistic quality and integrity of work
sponsored by outside agencies whether
they be the National Science Foundation
or the National Endowment for the Arts
this is a principle that we have had
some trouble sustaining over the past
several years in our relationship with
the federal government in many
dimensions last year's controversy over
the funding of the Corporal politics
exhibit at the list Center was but one
case in point and I do not want to dwell
on that particular event because it is
just a single example of the need to
renew the partnership between our
universities and our government to
rebuild a mutual commitment to investing
in our long-term future through
education scholarship and research the
time is right for rigorous and high
level examination of the federal
government's complex role as a patron of
the Arts this conference provides an
excellent opportunity to work together
to delineate the issues and articulate
our expectations regarding the role of
creative expression in our society and
the role of arts and the education of
our young people I am delighted that all
of you are here and I certainly look
forward eagerly to the results of your
deliberations now it is my very great
pleasure to introduce our two
distinguished keynote speakers for this
evening
you will hear first from Senator Edward
M Kennedy of Massachusetts who for 30
years as a member of the Senate has
played a leading role in the affairs of
our nation he has been an eloquent
spokesman for the less privileged in
this country and for human rights
internationally he certainly
has been a strong and effective advocate
for higher education for the advancement
of research and for the financial
support of needy college students his
legendary for his tireless and fruitful
work on behalf of the causes he believes
in senator Kennedy has chaired numerous
key Senate committees and currently as
chair of the Committee on labor and
Human Resources which among its many
other duties will oversee the upcoming
reauthorization hearings for the
National Endowment for the Arts he will
be followed by Robert Hughes author and
art critic who reaches 20 million people
a week through his reviews in Time
magazine mr. Hughes is the most widely
read art critic writing today in the
English language he is also a
best-selling historian and one of the
most popular art lecturers in America
his most recent book the culture of
complaint is a critique of American
politics and culture and has received
numerous enthusiastic reviews I'm sure
that his observations this evening will
give us much to think about and to
debate over the course of this meeting
and beyond first then man may I
introduce senator Kennedy
you say that that's a little local
better perception and I received the
other day I was down in the southern
part of Virginia speaking and someone
was introducing me and I've got to some
of the people in the audience and said
that Kennedy's a horse's tail words to
that effect and what happened but some
of the other people at the head table
dragged this person out of the room and
I said well I didn't know this was a
Kennedy country and they said it isn't
it's horse country and I don't want to
hear too much applause okay I want to
thank president best for his generous
remarks and he truly is an outstanding
president for this outstanding
institution and I'm honored to be here
with him today for this impressive
conference and I also want to command
Ellen Harris mark Cal Graham and the MIT
Office of the Arts for convening this
timely forum on public policy and the
federal role in the arts the arts are a
central part of all of our lives and
support for the arts is an important
principle of federalism that I strongly
support and it's part of our national
responsibility to encourage a climate in
this country that promotes development
of the Arts and encourages understanding
and participation in music and
literature and painting sculpture and
dance and many other creative forms of
expression MIT is an ideal venue for
this conference this incomparable
institution has produced some of the
finest scientists and thinkers of our
time and it is no coincidence that MIT
also has a long-standing policy that
encourages training in the arts as a
means to foster creative thinking and
well-rounded human development one of
your distinguished professors has
recently captured the wonderful blend of
art and science as an inspired novel
Einsteins dream it is a warm and
intimate portrait of that famous
scientist and I commend him for his
achievement professor Allan Lichtman it
is also a special honor to share this
podium this evening with another
brilliant writer who is also a noted
critic I the honor of meeting him last
year at the Kennedy School of Government
and some privileged to be with him now
Robert Hughes as some of you know
or may know I love to paint with mixed
results
my artist friends have long advised me
to stick to politics and my Republican
colleagues in the Senate are urging me
to switch full-time to painting the
creative arts represent our common
heritage and the universal need for
positive expression they simultaneously
represent the most personal of our
individual human feelings and the most
universal linking us to our common
humanity some nations and leaders have
attempted to censor expression they felt
was excessive for seditious or merely
inappropriate but censorship has never
silenced art for long in any land and in
a congressional hearing on the National
Endowment for the Arts a few years ago
the great conductor rostropovich spoke
eloquently of the artists in his Russian
homeland who live with censorship and
sometimes lived in exile creative
expression still endure and great
composers such as Shostakovich coffee
often composed wonderful works but as
Rostropovich sadly noted their fellow
citizens were never permitted by their
government to share the joy of these
masterpieces it is remarkable and
destructive that the leader who guided
Czechoslovakia out of its dark years of
oppression was a great writer and a
vision visionary Michael hable the soul
of a nation cannot be extinguished by
any censor it is not only foolhardy but
futile for politicians to attempt to
write guidelines for acceptable art the
arts defying orthodoxy or any other form
of mediocrity regrettably in recent
years the most public discussion of the
Arts in this country has been the debate
over controversial works supported by
the National Endowment this debate
misstates the mission of the endowment
and insults its proud record of
achievement over the past quarter
century it takes a very narrow-minded
critic to see the molehill and miss the
mountain the arts endowment does not
belong to any one person or political
party it reflects the national
spirit and broad diversity in our
country it always has and it always
should but the endowment is a fragile
institution it will survive only as long
as the peer panel system not political
second guessing system determines which
applications for support are funded
artistic excellence not political
passion must guide these decisions
occasional mistakes should not become
the pretext for destroying its noble
mission or hamstringing its procedures
the great irony of this debate is that
what senator Jesse Helms and his
indecency Brigade want to do with Soviet
eyes American art as all of you know the
lists center became part of the national
controversy when an application to
support an MIT exhibition was rejected
by the endowment and to your credit and
the endowments discredit the show went
on with private support replacing the
federal supported deserve incredibly the
acting chairman of the endowment
subverted her agency's own procedures
she ignored the recommendation of the
National Council on the arts and the
peer-review system steps established by
statute to avoid just this type of
political intrusion into the endowments
deliberation a national conference like
this is an appropriate forum to state
and restate some fundamental principles
and avoid a repetition of distressing
incidents like that in a time of other
urgent needs and few resources to meet
them some conclude that we cannot afford
to support the Arts but that view is
short-sighted federal support for the
Arts is an investment in the future
that will bring important benefits to
the quality of life in our communities a
recent national poll found that fully 92
percent of Americans say that the arts
are important to the life of their
neighborhoods and they also they are
also important to their economies ticket
sales to performing arts events surpass
spectator sports by over a billion
dollars in 1989 in Charleston South
Carolina the Stiletto USA festival
has brought 30 million a year to the
city in the past ten years and in
Massachusetts the impact has been just
as dramatic from 1987 and 91 state and
federal funds for the Arts total almost
120 million dollars and reached over 200
million people and one and a half
million artists federal support provides
the essential seed money for broader
state and local private aid nationwide
the federal investment is less than 70
cents a citizen a year arguably is one
of the best investments the federal
government can make our artists are also
our most visible goodwill ambassadors
abroad Aaron Copland Leonard Bernstein
Agnes DeMille and Martha Graham are
quintessentially American artists but
their appeal is worldwide and so to
ernest hemingway Emily Dickinson William
Faulkner our great American writers
whose words reach out and touch the
world the appeal of our artist was
dramatically demonstrated on
Inauguration Day last January when Maya
Angelou recited her beautiful poem
celebrating the American national spirit
and the sense of renewal that all of us
felt that day in her 1972 autobiography
vol I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings
return to the bestseller list and has
been there ever since a miracle of
marketing no a miracle of art President
Kennedy understood the importance of the
Arts the Center for the Performing Arts
that bears his name in Washington is a
fitting living memorial to his vision on
its walls are carved his words which
symbolized the hope he had for our
country and his belief that we reached
the highest when we reach deepest within
ourselves I am certain that after the
dust of centuries has passed over our
cities we too will be remembered not for
our victories or defeats in battle or in
politics but for our contribution to the
human spirit the art Chronicle our
history record our successes warned of
our weaknesses expand our understanding
they challenge us
not just to do better but to do our best
federal support to institutions and
individuals must be accompanied by
accountability like any other federal
program but federal support should not
be conditioned or encumbered by
restrictions that interfere with
artistic freedom any more than any
federal aid to education should be used
to interfere with academic freedom in
testimony before Congress constitutional
scholar Kathleen Sullivan warned against
content content restrictions on federal
aid to the arts we are each masters in
our own homes there we may pick and
choose the ideas to which we open our
doors or minds but in the government's
house all ideas are welcome sometimes
art shocks our sensibilities it is
supposed to but that is no justification
for unwarranted intrusions by extremists
who if the truth be known oppose any
federal aid to the arts obscenity is the
place to draw the line federal dollars
should not be spent on any project that
is obscene current law explicitly
prohibits funding for such projects your
funds are awarded for such purposes they
must be refunded the proper way to
determine obscenity is through the
courts a new round of contentious debate
about these principles is on the horizon
in Congress the Senate must confirm a
new head of the arts endowment and we
must pass new authorizing legislation
for the agency
Congress will consider a two-year
extension of the endowment in the months
ahead this short-term action will permit
the new administration to install a new
team at the endowment and to participate
fully in a comprehensive debate about
these issues by any fair accounting the
endowment has fulfilled its mission it
has done an exceptional job in providing
support to the nation's cultural
institutions and it has dramatically
increased the people's access to the
Arts the challenge for both the
administration and the Congress is to
guide the endowment beyond the current
criticism and
University the past administration was
willing to be part of the problem rather
than seek a fair solution with the new
administration we have an excellent
chance to restore confidence in the
agency and provide a new sense of
purpose for its mission now is not the
time nor I hope will there ever come a
time to turn our back on this essential
public commitment to the Arts and free
expression in closing let me say again
that it is an honor to be a part of this
conference I look forward to the results
of your deliberation and I'm grateful to
you for including me in this important
discussion thank you
well ladies and gentlemen when mr.
Clinton and the Democrats came to power
in Washington a few months ago there was
a good deal of optimistic talk among the
chattering classes to which I belong
about the end of idealogy in American
politics after the bruising divisions of
the 80s a time of healing characterized
by something called a search for the
center was supposed to be upon us the
alternative which was set forth in a
speech to the Republican convention in
Houston by Pat Buchanan the only man of
our generation who ever made me feel
however briefly ashamed to be Irish the
well the alternative was just too ugly
to contemplate that rhetoric of revenge
of cultural war remember that taking
America back street-by-street from those
who were not really Americans such as
blacks and homosexuals and liberals and
atheists now Bush had allowed his
program to be written by the right wing
of his own party unfortunately which
staked everything upon the idea of a
cultural and religious struggle winning
it was going to return America to its
original virtues which had been in
steady decline despite nearly 15 years
of Republican rule since the New Deal
and once the Republicans had lost many
liberals hoped that these specters of
ideological intolerance would begin to
retreat baffled and defeated from the
field of culture hadn't they tried to
fight an election on cultural issues and
lost wouldn't they conclude from this
that America's overriding problem might
indeed be the economy stupid and not the
issues so richly symbolized in the
various attacks upon the National
Endowment for the Arts that were
launched in the late 80s well the short
answer is no there is no sign of an end
to ideological division in America and
still less is there any sign of healing
in the field of culture and the arts
in fact the splits only seem to get
wider and the shouting across them
louder Jesse Helms and Brazil spent a
few months licking their wounds but now
rest assured they are looking their
chops and they will be back and with
reinforcements what happened to the NEA
in the late 80s was probably only a
prelude to what is likely to happen in
the immediate future and a few years
down the road as the millennial year
2000 approaches the morals of public
funding is too hot and too handy a baton
to remain unpressed for long now thus
far nobody has been appointed as the new
director of the NEA and we don't know
who it's likely to be nor do I know what
the president's cultural policies are in
fact likely to be I earnestly pray that
we cannot deduce them from the
inauguration festivities
stage-managed by a couple of sitcom
producers and stuffed with Hollywood
celebs with the sole concession to high
culture being a poem by Maya Angelou on
whose merits I disagree with Senator
Kennedy the most urgent one however it's
the most urgent priority it seems to me
ought to be defending the endowment well
one of the most urgent priorities ought
to be defending the endowment against
the pressures of both the right and the
left in America if there was ever a time
when we needed to think clearly and
openly about what the National Endowment
for the Arts can and can't do it is now
the NEA is an institution unique to
America it is also quite young from the
Declaration of Independence until the
1960s there had been absolutely no
tradition of federal support for the
Arts in this country although there had
been intermittent stamps at it and where
federal money and arts policy crossed
there were usually long delays and quite
a lot of rancor and a tremendous amount
of log rolling and many and the opening
of many pork barrels controversy for
instance over the monument to George
Washington in the 19th century which
took something like seventy years to
build was as fierce as it was over my
limbs Vietnam Memorial in the 20th
traditional American they say fair left
no room for federal arts subsidies after
all why should it in a country that also
rejected such novelties as public
housing or health care or unemployment
insurance City money went to the
construction of civic centers between
1900 and 1950 and there were significant
tax exemptions for donors for concert
halls for museums but active funding of
the Arts from Washington was kept to the
very bare minimum as a result what was
performed exhibited and played in
American institutions between the wars
was largely Europe dominated and Europe
driven now as James harborin and Charles
gray have pointed out in their book the
economics of art and culture which is
due from Cambridge University Press
I believe in August and is the best
introduction that I know it
the labyrinth of echo of the economics
of American culture this situation began
to change in the 1950s when the Ford
Foundation began a program of grants for
American symphony orchestras but the big
push for large-scale funding of the Arts
from state and federal governments
started in the early 60s at the state
level it began as many of you will
recall when Governor Nelson Rockefeller
set up the New York State Council on the
Arts who's funding mr. peek at in 1976
at 35 million dollars a year the idea of
the National Endowment for the Arts the
NEA
was proposed in 1961 under John Kennedy
by August Heckscher and Lyndon Johnson
pushed it through after Kennedy's
assassination the twin sister agencies
the NEA and the neh were written into
law in 1965 and then as now these
agencies were strongly opposed in
Congress by Southern Democrats and
conservative Republicans there was in
those days actually a group of people
core conservative Republicans and there
never has been a consensus on the need
for national cultural endowment in
America and the arguments against them
have scarcely changed in 50 years they
lead to government control of culture
which tastes of socialism or else
promotes mediocrity they cost too much
they're worth can't be shown on a
balance sheet they reduced the virtues
of private patronage more recently and
this is argued from controversy over
five or six grants among the tens of
thousands made by the NEA in the last 30
years they spread filth and immorality
now right from the start
the NEA was only interested in fostering
the production of new works of art and
in contemporary institutional practice
matters of historical preservation which
are very much to the fore in the
thinking of cultural agencies in
European countries were not within its
purview as they are for instance within
the purview of the minister the
ministries of culture of France or
Germany or Italy the NE
his budget began in 65 at 10 million a
year and it reached its peak of
effective spending power which was a
hundred and fifty million in 1979 and
though the nominal budget has gone as
high as 180 million in the years since
when you figure in inflation the present
spending power of the NEA is somewhere
around 40 percent below its actual value
of 15 years ago it is about what one
Japanese collector a forest rific or mr.
Saito paid for two paintings they forgot
and a Renoir just before the art market
crash in 1990 it is also less per capita
actually than the money given in
cultural support by the states now this
compared to other countries was and is a
tiny and miniscule and most parsimonious
subsidy a study done by mark Shuster for
the NEA and 85 showed that the showed
that America was then giving three
dollars per capita to the arts in direct
federal and state aid as against thirty
five dollars in Sweden 32 in Canada and
France and so on down to nine dollars
and 60 cents in Margaret Thatcher's
Great Britain however this wasn't the
whole story of course because none of
these countries gave significant
indirect support of the Arts by allowing
business or personal tax deductions for
gifts factor those in and American
support went up to somewhere around
about $13 per capita above Great Britain
certainly but still below or the rest
well there is a further component which
wholly depends upon the NEA which is the
matching grant by which the NEA puts it
as it were as often being said it's a
Good Housekeeping Seal of Approval on a
project by giving half the money and
thus inducing another sponsor corporate
round or whatever to pony up the rest
the NEA is and is now and always has
function - airs a vital capital a vital
catalyst for non government money for
the Arts and there seems to me to be no
convincing evidence
that what conservatives claim namely
that private money would rush in to fill
the gap if the NEA were to go out of
business is true or even remotely
probable for as a rule corporate money
lacks prestige ventures proven successes
wants to know in advance that it's going
to be a Broadway hit whereas it's
essential to the NEA is manda as it was
conceived and as I believe it should
continue to go to care for what is
unproven for what cannot yet succeed
necessarily in the marketplace you can
contrast the position of the head of the
NEA
with that atmosphere Jacques to beau who
is the new administrator could cure in
France - beau actually wanted a he's a
lawyer and he wanted the Ministry of
Justice but his wife has a interest in
the arts and so he settled for the
Ministry of Culture in which position he
disposes of an annual budget of
approximately two billion dollars 100
times the American equivalent with which
he can Commission works of art for the
state and restore gothic churches and
defend the purity of the French language
prospect which I guess would give
nightmares to anybody who tried the same
thing in Washington today to build opera
houses and to underwrite the French film
industry with the help of attacks of
17.5% which is applied to every ticket
to an American movie that sold in France
and it is in this way that Arnold
Schwarzenegger pays for Gerard Depardieu
he stands at the top of a pyramid of
interlocking cultural interest which
resembles the court of louis xiv except
that it's much bigger and has been
magnified over the last 20 years by the
requirements of fluorometer Anne's and
Jacqueline's champagne socialism a state
subsidized composer official composer
like Pierre Boulle Ayres is as a result
by far the most indulged and politically
powerful man probably in the entire
history of musical politics in France or
anywhere else to compare his influence
to that say of Philip Glass or the late
John Cage in
America is like comparing ants and
elephants as Benjamin Disraeli observed
if you want to know what envy is you
must live among artists and if one and
one remembers the words of a 19th
century French Minister of Culture who
no doubt after a particularly trying day
in the office remarked that every time I
award a commission I create one in great
and 30 malcontents such were the joys of
patronage but what would make even
sponsorship wholly impractical or
particularly on the NEA s tiny budget is
the conservative agenda the agenda of
some conservatives at least of pre
vetting or grants for the moral content
of their supposed results a perp from
the difficulty I mean there's a worthy
existential difficulty of censoring a
work of art before it is actually made
modern democracy I think cannot
contemplate without revulsion the
machinery of supervision that this would
entail as a matter of fact neither can
many conservatives imagine it which is
why they say you should just get rid of
the NEA better no sponsorship at all and
the risk of blasphemy or buggery on
government money in fact many
conservatives seem to me to be caught in
a sort of contradiction on cultural
subsidies half of them saying that the
National Endowment should fold because
it's a latest and the other half
claiming that in the end only high
culture is worth having and that the NEA
should go because it doesn't aim high
enough the taxpayers money question is
of course an extremely thorny well the
American right likes to brandish it as
though it were completely unanswerable
and the difficulty for the left and the
center is that they have used it so
often themselves against government
spending that they don't like you know
such as military waste if your sense of
frugality is offended by the famous
thousand dollar ratchet wrench or the
$600 toilet seat in a bomber why
shouldn't someone else raise a hue and
cry about 40 grands worth of NEA money
going to subsidize a photography show
that includes a picture of the artist
with the bullwhip
his bat well it is true that the money
wasn't very much in the scheme of
American budgets it represented about
140th of one percent of one copper penny
for every man woman and child in this
democracy nevertheless as was frequently
pointed out it was public money all the
same and the point made by Jesse Helms
and Donald Wildmon and their ilk was
that no son however small ought to be
spent by government on the dissemination
of images or ideas that some part of the
taxpaying public might find morally
repulsive therefore let these artists do
their stuff as the saying went on their
own time and on their own dime and never
mind that neither Mapplethorpe's or
serrano actually received a cent of
government money themselves from making
their disputed images in other words to
qualify for government support through
the NEA a work of art had to satisfy
what these people imagined to be a moral
consensus it had to be in essence
incapable of offending anybody no matter
how low his or her threshold of offense
might actually be now the obvious
problem is that in a society containing
something like 260 million people there
is probably no such work of art not even
a nude by Renoir or a naked baby Jesus
by Andrea della robia the in solubility
of the problem appears if you reflect
upon the amendment which Jesse Helms and
Al D'Amato and Orrin Hatch those three
musketeers of morality tried to read
into law the Helms agreement proposed
that no government funds should be given
by the NEA to quote promote disseminate
or produce in its exact words one
obscene or indecent materials including
but not limited to depictions of
sadomasochism homoeroticism the
exploitation of children or individuals
engaged in sex acts or to material which
denigrates the objects or beliefs of the
adherents of a particular
or long religion or or three material
which denigrates to bases or reviles a
person group or class of citizens on the
basis of race creed sex handicap age or
national origin
unquote now the most obvious and curious
feature of the Helms amendment was that
if it had not issued from the lips of a
famously right-wing Republican senator
you could have mistaken it and
especially clauses two and three to any
ruling on campus speech limitations
recently proposed by there's other
self-appointed censors who are cutting
loose in our harried society those
hypocritical pests of a khadeem the
politically correct it was hard to know
exactly what Helms meant by a particular
religion or non religion pantheism but
certainly Clause three made it clear
that he was against racism sexism
ableism lookism
and any of the other offenses against
social etiquette whose prescription by
PC was already causing such mirth and
laughter among old conservatives off
campus and creating lot a few new ones
on it and thus extremes tend to meet in
fact the homes agreement was so broadly
drafted as to be virtually meaningless
its effect would have been to create a
kind of Loony parody of cultural
democracy in which every citizen became
his or her own take over censor all that
a work of art would need to be defunded
or if shown in a museum under NEA
auspices removed from view would be to
offend anybody for practically any
reason at all the amendment was thus a
sort of crystallization in very pure
form of our present culture of complaint
into law it would have made the National
Endowment hostage to every crank
ideologue and god-bothering in America a
grant for the exhibition of say gothic
ivories
could be pulled on the grounds that the
material was objectionable to Jews as
much medieval art is deeply anti-semitic
or to Muslims because who you know is
one of those ivories not have contained
and not uncommon figure of false
prophets boiling in hell with Muhammad's
which was quite a favorite in the Middle
Ages or for that matter to atheists
offended by the use of government money
to insert any sort of religious
propaganda including ancient ivory
carvings into a museum and indeed one
could imagine some Stalinist feminists
complaining about a third that a 13th
century who complained that a 13th
century depiction of a patriarchal God
or the sexism implicit in a subservient
or tempting Eve was repugnant to her
religion or non religion under the Helms
amendments a fire worshiper might well
claim that the presence of extinguishers
in the museum was repulsive to his deity
now Helms and his supporters were of
course at pains to deny that the
amendment had anything at all to do with
censorship nevertheless one would have
needed to be remarkably naive to suppose
that censorship was not the root of this
controversy the efforts to cut off
government money from offensive earth
were but the tip of a general efforts
growing on the right to repress all
offensive art subsidized or not under
the assumption basically of their
proponents that the stuff doesn't you
know isn't a necessary part of social
discourse anyway the wisest analysis of
this problem was offered some months
later by a Jesuit Father the Reverend
Timothy Healy the director of the New
York Public Library now our last dead
the debate is about censorship father
Healy declared to a House Subcommittee
on post-secondary education in November
1989 and he went on against the argument
that the artist is free to write to
paint or to compose as he pleases
without federal subsidy we must urge
that to deprive an artist of that
subsidy because of the content of his
work is a clear and strong kind of
censorship the counter-argument is
really a dodge the mixing up of the
realm of law with the realm of morals is
deadly law can tolerate
evils that morality condemns we have a
good law if it can be obeyed if it is
enforceable and if it is so prudently
drafted that it avoids most of the
harmful effects that flow from it if a
law does none of these things it is a
bad law no matter what the logic or the
moral intensity behind it
unquote though none of the arguments
heard on the Senate floor attained the
clarity and sophistication of this
priests words the Helms amendment was
voted down but its defeat did not dispel
the idea that the US government
implicitly puts its moral weight behind
all the art that it found that the
artist with an NEA grant becomes as it
were the voice of the state and that the
state is therefore to be held
responsible for what he or she makes
more sense
the NEA however was never conceived as
an arm of state propaganda except in the
very general sense that Kennedy Johnson
and their advisers felt that America
should support its own artists and would
in some general way look better for
doing so there is a huge difference
between commissioning a work of art and
sponsoring a talent the patron says the
committee is commissioning something I
want a mural with me on horseback
showing democracy trampling on ignorance
and moreover after that I want away in
the mural the NEA essentially puts a
dent a bet on talent at arm's length
through the peer-review system and then
it gets out of the way once you forget
the difference between state
commissioning and this kind of
sponsorship every attack upon the NEA
becomes possible I mean this was the
confusion that behind the culture wars
equivalent of the Willie Horton ad Pat
Buchanan was noted TV spot attacking
George Bush through the NEA and PBS when
so many of you must have seen this one
you saw clips from a documentary that
had been made for PBS about gays the
clips were liver queens capering in the
street and the course of a march and
over there supporting
Analia they came the voice of a narrator
saying that this is what George Bush was
investing your tax dollars in note the
use of the verb investing in half-naked
gays the way that his father used to
invest in oil windows here was Bush
putting your money into a kind of
Wildcat scheme for the propagation of
homosexuality but actually that isn't
the way it works the idea behind the NEA
fundamentally is that a democracy can
subsidize a forum an Agora a marketplace
of ideas and images without specifying
in advance what kind of images and ideas
should be displayed in it this certainly
reminds upon some kind of an agreement
some kind of an agreement of common
interest between the sponsor and the
artist but there are plenty of
precipitous for us and there are plenty
of working parallels to it in American
life already when for instance a
university gets federal state or city
funds they come with the assumption that
the place will remain free from
ideological pressure and that any issue
can be reasonably exposed and debated on
campus if this isn't so the university
state subsidized wholly or partially
cannot function as a place of teaching
and learning the fact that public money
is involved does not mean that the
university should avoid or skirt
controversial ideas or punish people for
uttering them the university has to
stick to that no matter how inconvenient
it may be and it sometimes is extremely
inconvenient for example I and many
other people regard Lynn or Jeffries as
an anti-semitic madman whose scholarship
is farcical but you cannot get rid of
him now by saying that the views that he
teaches are offensive to most Americans
blacks included and that since CCNY gets
dollars from the taxpayer he should for
that reason be four stars or an even
more basic level this city like any
other in America has parks and squares
and streets which are maintained by
public funds and yet it is perfectly
legal to express your views in them
those views may be to others that is a
basic path of citizens rights under the
First Amendment if I want to demonstrate
for or against abortion in that
state-sponsored civic space I can if I
want to propose voting rights for
insects or urge the immediate
repatriation of all Catholics from
Boston to Ireland I can do that too I
may not succeed but I can do it the
assumption behind this and behind the
NEA
too is that the diversity in inner
democracy is good we agree to pool our
tax dollars to create a general frame in
which opinions can be freely uttered and
images freely propagated any opinions
however much they may annoy or offend
somebody else who also has the right to
express his or her opinions no matter
how repugnant I might find them does
this mean that the NEA is obliged to
subsidize any and every kind of
utterance without aesthetic moral
political or other distinctions or
considerations I don't believe so no
sponsors still ness patron in the
history of art has ever done this but it
does then that the NEA has to be
prepared to resist unreasonable pressure
not only from the moralists and censors
of the fundamentalist right with their
kant about family values but also from
the censorious left with it's consistent
portrayal of the liberal ideal that high
cultural standards can be popularly
accepted and practiced it has got to
shift its attention away from the
cliches of our time the chatter about
empowerment the obsession with
resentment as a cultural standard there
is a right jaw of the vise and there is
a left one and between the two the NEA
is painfully squeezed and may in the end
be distorted out of useful shape these
pressures are the outcome both of the PC
belief that the personal is the
political acts of imagination not
exempted and of the conservative view
that any stick you can beat liberals
with is a good stick and never mind what
else gets flattened in the struggle the
National Endowment for the Arts was not
in fact designed to be an arena for such
disputes and thus it proved
extraordinarily awkward and even inept
at responding to them and its response
is complicated by the claims of
activists start to constitute an
avant-garde the population of the art
world expanded enormous ly in the 1980s
and in an overpopulated art world with a
depressed market you are going to hear
more and more about discrimination
against artists endless complaints about
racism sexism and so on whereas the
fundamental and underlying problem is
that there are too many artists of all
kinds in America for the base of
collectors and sponsors to support that
is why the National Endowment for the
Arts really matters in the ecology of
American culture but it cannot do good
work in my opinion if it caves into the
forced politics of group entitlement the
sense of disenfranchisement among
artists has led to a stream of attacks
upon the idea of quality as though it
were the enemy of justice quality the
argument goes is a plot it is the result
of a conspiracy to marginalize the work
of other races other cultures by you
know the play or patriarchal penis
people and to invoke its presence in
works of art is somehow inherently
repressive this drivel has become the
new orthodoxy and fewer and fewer
critics and historians seem able to
resist it more and more it is assumed
that one's cultural reach is fixed and
determined forever by whatever slot one
is raised in you could imagine the
contempt with which a great Mexican
artist like Diego Rivera would have
reacted to this Rivera probably gave
more to Mexico in terms of
self-knowledge and cultural pride than
any artist whose name we know in its
entire history but he was only able to
do so because he had absorbed and
completely internalized the great
tradition of Renaissance fresco painting
which combined with his absorption in
French modernism pre-columbian Mexican
art and living folk art to produce the
tremendous from results that we see on
such walls as those of palacio nacional
in mexico city if you had told Rivera
that quality didn't matter he would have
laughed in your face now you can't deny
that at any time in the history of Earth
they have been inflated reputation
and wrongly ignored artists certainly
this is as true today as it ever was
this happens in the short term but in
the long run the in justices do tend to
be corrected there remains for instance
practically no institutional bias
against women artists in America anymore
than there is a bias against women
writers in American publishing and this
is certainly very different that the
America that I first came to in 1970 and
yet you have to bear in mind that not
all artists are wrongly ignored
mediocrity is the natural fate of most
creative endeavor especially in a
society which in the name of
therapeutics and personal growth has
removed most of the rigor from the
training of its artists
most are made by white Americans is
mediocre most art made by black
Americans is mediocre most stuff made by
Chinese Americans Japanese Americans and
American Indians is mediocre too and
most art made by women is as mediocre as
most art made by men the same applies to
gays and straights into all the other
polarities we must therefore be
extremely wary of the sentimentality
that institutional multi-culti breeds
those who talk about remedial
multiculturalism as a radical program
and as anybody who's read my book will
know I am very much a friend about a
cultural ISM and I am totally in favor
of it otherwise I would not have been I
would never have left my own country to
begin with in order to start trying to
see through the scrims that divide us
and understand other people's image
banks but this is not what is meant so
often by multiculturalism in the society
but is meant so often as a sort of
separatism anyway those who talk about
remedial multi-culti as a radical
program fail to see how conventional
izing and soothing and altogether
consoling to middlebrow taste its
effects can tend to be one already sees
this in one area that is publicly-funded
art where multicultural programs serve
to get the embattled National Endowment
for the Arts off the hook of making any
discriminations at all if the
Philistines are baying for an end to
government support for high art the
difficult and possibly controversial art
and if meanwhile the moralists are
yelling for the blood of any poet or
performer whose work might raised
hackles in some goth club in Tulsa
then what could be a better refuge than
multiculturalism just turned the already
meager trickle of government money
towards stuff that nobody could plural
with areas such as to quote from a
recent brochure issued by the NEA as
last director and Imelda raditch II
quote among needlework coastal seagrass
basketry
southeast Alaskan native does
american-indian basketry and woodcraft
pacific island canoe building and
Appalachians banjo playing this
sentimental form of cultural diversity
as interpreted by federal funding
agencies and an increasing number of
private foundations may or may not pick
some good stuff out of the woodpile but
most of the time it engage it entails
pious gestures of cultural support while
actually producing remarkably little
that would in aesthetic terms challenge
refine criticize or in any way extend
the thinking of the status quo under the
rubric of self esteem they tend they
foster mediocre art for a populace
mentality that contents itself with
relatively easy tasks expressed in the
jargon of supporting ethnicity and
gender differences in the arts instead
of the harder one of looking for real
excellence too much of the art that
results from such programs turns out to
be affirmative prolix Kitsch gassing
with sincerity and people like it for
the same reasons that they like Hallmark
cards with Sumi a herons and New Age
verses on them it just makes them feel
good now you can certainly run a
feel-good cultural program on
sociological and statistical criteria
backing it up with the usual parties
about empowerment and this conforms very
well to the evangelical tradition of
American cultural life the idea that one
is morally improved uplifted and turned
into a better citizen by producing or
consuming art but the art that it
fosters maybe and sometimes is quite
banal what happens where government arts
money and populist multiculturalism
intersect all too often a form of moral
blackmail with one eye on the Pope
barrel now in Holland for the last 20
years they tried the form of populist
pork for everybody the government set up
a fund to buy work by artists no matter
how good it was all the method was that
the artist should be a alive
and be Dutch about 8,000 Dutch artists a
representative that connection none of
it is shown and as everybody in Holland
including most of the artists involved I
feel now admits about 98% of it is
rubbish the storage expenses are so high
that they have to get rid of the staff
but they can't because nobody wants it
they tried giving it to public
institutions like lunatic asylums and
hospitals but even the lunatic asylums
insisted upon standards they wanted to
pick and choose so there it all sits
Democratic non hierarchical non-elite
non-sexist unsaleable and for the great
regret of the Dutch authorities only
partially biodegradable now there are
lessons from this and that we suggest to
them the first is that if Dutch mad
houses can discriminate again about us
without being accused of anti-democratic
a leaders and so can the NEA but mind
you I speak as an unrepentant elitist I
don't think democracy is any guide to
taste I think the job of democracy in
the field of art is to make the world
safe for a leathe ism
not only leaders and based upon race or
money or social position but on skill
and imagination and the embodiment of
high ability and intense vision is
basically the only thing that does make
art popular it is why the Rijksmuseum is
full of people and the remedial art
basements of Amsterdam are not the
greatest popular spectacles in America
are elitist to the core football games
basketball games professional tennis but
nobody is going to pay to watch Hilton
Kramer and me swim the 800 meter
freestyle in 35 minutes flat despite our
relatively privileged position as white
European males like sport art is an area
in which a leaf ism can display itself
at a negligible cost in social hub the
second lesson is that if a scrupulous
participatory democracy like Holland
spends 25 times per taxpayer what
America does our culture choosing art on
sociological grounds in the name of
complete cultural a gala tere anism and
then ends up with a garbage disposal
problem what guarantee is there that we
can do much better here absolutely no
guarantee that I can see it is in the
nature of human beings to discriminate
we make choices and judgments every day
these choices are part of real
experience they are influenced by others
of course but they are not fundamentally
the result of a passive reaction to
Authority and we know I think that one
of the realest experiences in cultural
life is that of a certain in quality
between books and musical performances
and paintings and other works of art
some things do strike us as better than
others aesthetically better more
articulate more radiant with
consciousness we may have difficulty
saying why but the experience remains
and aesthetic discrimination must not be
tarred with the brush of racial or
gender discrimination it corresponds to
experience just as our perception and
comparison of Grace in the work of a
basketball player or a tennis pro rises
from experience and these differences of
intensity and meaning and grace can't be
set forth in a little catechism or a
recipe book they can only be experienced
and
argued and then seen in relation to the
history that of course must include
social history now the NEA as I
understand it was founded in order to
identify to pick out those sparks in the
cultural campfire around which we all
sit wherever they may be found to found
them to give them oxygen to bring them
into flame this is the way that
sponsorship makes its modest bits about
the future the moment you go to other
criteria you may be in trouble if you
reform your program in terms of agendas
based on the artists race or gender or
supposed degree of cultural
enfranchisement if you start agonizing
for instance about whether the quotes
the quota of grants to Hispanic
activists video artists has been
fulfilled you will have no answer to the
conservatives who then turn around and
want to know why the NEA isn't giving
equal grants to Christian fundamentalist
poster designers I am certainly an
elitist in that I believe in high
aesthetic standards and I think the NEA
should too I'm also a populist in that I
believe that these standards can and do
make sense to people who are prepared to
pay enough attention the surest way to
convert the NEA into a dead-letter is to
make its sponsorship an area for battles
many of which do indeed need to be
fought but fought in the sphere of
politics
the trouble with fighting political
battles on cultural turf is twofold
first as many of us will recall from the
1960s they are rarely won there and
secondly in the process you may simply
kill the grass so that everybody loses
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes yes well it doesn't seem to me that
you need to be an unusually wealthy
person to afford a ticket to the bust
and symptoms could have better phrased
by saying that they were taking music
which some of which they rate you know
it's not true that all the music that
the Boston performs or any other
Symphony performs was actually written
at the behest of Kings but some of which
let's say for the sake of argue it was
performed by kings and recycling it back
to people who are not Kings in other
words recycling it back to the citizens
of a democracy rich and poor I mean the
idea that the the it seems to me
profoundly condescending to suppose
the only people who are interested in
what is for convenience called high
culture are the rich it is not true and
if it were true every music or every
every Symphony Hall in America would
have closed in long ago if classical
music didn't have some kind of popular
base it couldn't say good deal with
merit to that criticism there is always
you know in any of the great problems of
setting up outstanding systems is to
avoid losses by log rolling by
favoritism by back scratching and you
know and simply by you know bureaucratic
friction and I think you know one of the
inherent problems of the NEA peer review
system is that you you know you get
chaps and check this as scratching one
another's back but when you think of the
alternative to it or the various
alternatives to it I think probably
there is still so you know quite a lot
to be said for the peer review system
but the idea that you know alas we do
not live you know you know utopian world
and it has never been possible to devise
you know you know I think probably not
since the time that Arg and Morgan first
did their first Buffalo and the
ordination caves it has not been
possible to devise a system of
outstanding that totally eliminated
favoritism of logrolling alas but the
question is because of that because arts
funding does not represent the you know
the sort of mechanisms of you know
of an ideal cultural world do you
therefore dispense with it I mean I
shudder to think of the number of really
rather mediocre works of art that you
know that have been commissioned you
know that were commissioned in France
through the 19th century quite a few and
endless protests from artists and
complaints from artists about the the
laxity the blindness the deafness the
the general unresponsiveness of culture
of bureaucrats I mean you read the
journals of Hector Berlioz for it's you
know one sees it at full stretch
nevertheless of the balance I think one
is great you know one is grateful in the
end that there was some kind of system
set up for the public encouragement of
the Arts on the results well at America
everybody sues everybody else
this is the most litigious society that
ever existed I think the the I have not
I have to tell you quite honestly I
haven't closely followed the the the ins
and outs of the the case that was
brought I think Bay by Karen Finley and
and holly Hughes and others against
against the NEA I mean my first reaction
was oh come on give me a break you know
the but but it revolves around the
question of whether active censorship
did indeed take place and I think the
court concluded that it did so but I'm
afraid that I haven't you know I mean
rather than my shame I have not followed
that I've not given that the attention
that I should have because I was working
on a book and so consequently I'm sorry
to pop out like this I really do feel
that you know it is hard to talk about
people's entitlements to a grant nobody
is entitled to a government grant I
think this has spin off from an
excessive kind of caricatured
sense of entitlement that runs to
America
[Music]
I used to chew mustard
yes I did yes sir
obviously you need a woman with the
reach of a gorilla and the balls of a
brass kangaroo the the phone buyer
fulfilled none of these requirements the
the I mean friend Mara is a very nice
bloke the the the you know he's yes not
a mean bone in his body
that's why his tenure at the NEA was
such a was so bedeviled the the in order
to resist the kind of political
opportunism that is thumping upon the I
mean you know there are various grounds
for criticizing the NEA which ranged
from shall we say at least an
intelligent conservative view of the
matter to you know this kind of lump of
opportunism which we see from you know
the the right Republicans are they were
just basically grandstanding and don't
give a damn about what the you know the
cultural health of this country might or
might not be and in order to resist this
well needs an extraordinary amounts you
just need to be extremely tough thrown
by wasn't tough nor do I believe that he
you know that he had his fundamental
cultural priorities in the right place
he came into there not quite knowing
what he thought brandishing his little
cello or whatever the hell it was he
plays and the the the know there are no
little cellos I'm sorry and the the and
he was like a fish out of water and the
the the subtitle of his book can fit
what was memoirs or confessions of an
arts warrior you know which suggests
some brave fellow going forth with his
magic sword to conquer the Mordor of
Washington well of course it's hokum you
know the the the he was the wrong you
know he was the wrong guy in the wrong
place
just as I would say an email derivative
was the wrong person in the wrong
place and anybody who goes into the into
running the NEA on the terms which were
dictated for rata G is also going to be
the wrong person in the wrong place
because if you have a supposedly
independent system of arts funding which
then becomes buffeted around in the
winds of whatever the electoral
requirements at the moment might be as
the NEA was as you know during thrown
buyers and radda Tory's tenure then you
know the institution is not well served
by those who run it yes sure I'm sorry
yeah I think it would be rather
difficult to make the argument for
increasing its funding fly although I do
actually believe that given its you know
it the NEA would probably might even do
better if it had more money at its
disposal the argument that I would make
is a very straightforward one really it
is that some degree of government
support for art for works of our be they
concerts or theatres over you know
whatever or performs of any kind or
paintings or sculpture is actually
necessary in a society where not
everything that is good can depend
automatically upon private or Institute
or or corporate institutional support
the second argument is that the main
function of the NEA is as I see it is to
act as a catalyst towards institutional
support for genuinely informative and
useful
kinds of culture or I had the word
cultural programming it's not to start
underst you know cultural events you
know the sustenance of museums and
sustenance of symphony orchestras and so
forth which actually you know after the
over-optimistic projections made in the
80s about how everything could be taking
over all this kind of support to be
taken up by the private sector it has
been fairly well shown that actually
it's not so easy for you know for the
private sector to come in fearlessly and
do it it needs a certain amount of
encouragement it needs to be led by the
nose the NEA has always had a very
important function in this relationship
the I would defend the NEA primarily as
catalyst and only in the second place as
patron and I would say to people who are
calling for a diminishment of its funds
that these funds were already cut to the
bone they are by comparison to other
great Democratic states in Europe almost
ludicrously low and that there is the
the that their present expenditure does
not involve any serious drainage from
other vital parts of national interest
so why not keep it going
oh I think there's no sign of weather I
think they have suitable criterion
criteria
[Music]
but it's often asked about what criteria
should be assumed by the NEA as if there
were a kind of yardstick which that
August institution could pull out of its
pocket and layers may alongside to work
about basically what the NEA does and
what I think it should do is make the
kind of educated guesses about
sensibility and its action in you know
about creative sensibility that you or I
might make as you know sort of literate
observers of whatever art we like and
then go ahead and do it on that basis in
other words I mean I tried earlier in
the speech to outline very strong you
know to argue very strongly that in the
first place
the NEA should be looking for some sort
of genuine and arguable excellence in
the with the hopefully in the results
that it subsidizes but that excellence
can only be argued in the presence of
the work of art this is one of the big
problems with funding things before they
actually take place you see the results
afterwards and it may you know work or
not but basically what they should be
doing is looking for serious talent
within the field that they wish to
subsidize and going on whatever
aesthetic criteria they believe to be
proper and which can be argued and I
believe they should be argued
yes we know that it's Picasso you go for
the work of art you go for the proof for
the personal or the group's past record
you look as attentively as you can at
what that person or group has done you
try to figure out therefore you know on
that basis whether that talent has the
kind of coherence and you know
adventurousness of spirit and you know
sort of intelligence of results that one
is looking for in a work of art it is
hard you know to as I say it is hard to
sort of invent a verbal three-foot rule
which you can then lay alongside you
know a play or a or a painting in
advance and say okay this measures up to
that this doesn't once appreciate you
know one's understanding of a work of
art isn't you know is essentially an
existential matter it happens you know
in the presence of the work you know you
get a some sort of a visceral reaction
and it's that you know it's the ability
of the thing to I suppose spark that
that promotes the faith in the you know
small act of faith in the artist that in
other words it is a subjective judgement
you cannot escape subjective judgments
by multiplying subjectivities in the
form of a committee it still ends up as
a subjective judgment and it has to be
pursued as such
[Music]
no I didn't say issues of
multiculturalism shouldn't be outside
issues of group entitlements triple-b
there's a very important distinction
they should be encouraging talent and
talent is not necessarily affection of
demographics they should be looking as
widely as they possibly can across the
Democratic Democratic the demographic
spectrum that goes without saying but in
the last analysis when it comes down to
what you're going to fund you're funded
on the basis of what you think is good
the work I mean they shouldn't be having
quotas for blacks or gays or women or
whites or whatever there should be no
such quotas in my opinion no but there
should be a very different openness to
all those groups and to all sectors of
society and there should be a profound
curiosity about what they're doing and
then at the end of the day you've still
got to make your judgment on the basis
of whether you think there's real talent
there or not
[Music]
well it depends on what you mean by
standards I mean if as many people think
you know standard you know there are
hermetically sealed different standards
from community to community why is it
that you or I could go into a museum and
look at a work of art from a culture
immensely separated from us in space and
time and you know cultural assumptions
you know such as for instance a bronze
pot from the true dynasty and find it
absolutely radiant with meaning and
beauty the the my view is that the idea
of differing aesthetic standards from
community to community as one which has
been tremendously inflated in America
and rather badly argued in point of fact
there is absolutely no reason on earth
that I could think of why for you know
why for instance a a white reader
wouldn't be able to get the point of
reading Langston Hughes or why a black
onlooker wouldn't be able to get into
the work of Piero della Francesca just
as much as a white one there is a I
think there is far too I think there is
a great deal of can't you know involved
in the inflation of the idea of
different differing aesthetic community
standards within on aesthetics within
America but my point is and I mean I
made it before I will make it again it
is absolutely essential that funding
bodies should look and pursue their a J
you know you know pursue their
investigation of what is out there as
widely as possible there must be no
group no person who is ineligible our
priority for this kind of support
well I think they already are and yes I
think they should be yes but again I
think it is rather difficult to you know
sort of formulate recipes for this you
know obviously you don't want monochrome
or monosexual bodies determining this
you know of course I mean it's a
democracy it should run it should run
across the spectrum but on the other
hand since Americans at the moment is so
fond of dividing themselves into micro
constituencies and then claiming that
each of these macro constituencies
represents a separate culture which very
often they really don't there is a
severe danger that that our process can
bog down and become just vociferous and
meaningless but in the broader you know
and the broader spectrum yes I think I
mean you know I think it would be
ridiculous for instance to you know to
sort of have some kind of a requirement
that each each review panel should
contain so many gays and so many
straights but the the you know on the
you know on the much larger divisions
men women blacks whites Hispanics
whatever yes I think there's a very
strong case to be made for that and in
practice it works out that way yes
no I do not know I think it would be a
dreadful idea think of what you'd get I
[Applause]
mean the only the only Minister of
Culture that any of us can imagine would
be ourselves you know the the we would
all you know on a certain level lack to
be the minister and I procure but it
ain't gonna happen and if it did happen
it would be somebody who would be you
know sort of just you know return into
the night there don't forget their I
mean you know the the the the it would
become such a you know that the way in
which the NEA became a partisan football
over the last few years I promise you
have been nothing compared to the
results of having a Minister of Culture
in this democracy I don't believe you
see that actually it works at all I
don't think it's altogether consistent
with the the democratic spirit of
America which we for under so much
admire I mean I really wouldn't want to
see an American Jack Lang and Jack Lang
in a certain sense once the American
Jacqueline
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see I think for instance that our
classes in schools can have a very
powerful educative effect you know they
you know they can be terrific for the
kids and not just because you know it's
teaching and finger-painting but because
it connects them to a whole mode of
experiencing the world which they would
not have otherwise and the idea that in
some way classes which expose the kids
to painting music dance whatever it
might be the theater is in some way
optional I think is very much you know I
think it's a tremendous pity looking
back on my own education which was
certainly a very much more classical and
rigorous I wouldn't say aunty art but
have just ignored it ignored the plastic
arts completely I'm at say but you know
there was the school did put on its
players and I you know I learned more
from being in those plays than I
probably in the end that was useful to
me in later life than I did from I'm
sorry to say this that I'd because I
wasn't very good at ancient Greek but
possibly more than I did from a shoe
from studying ancient Greek but the the
there is always a tendency and it's true
in Australia too and it's true in
England you know as well as in America
Americans are not sort of actually some
bunch of 260 million isolated
Philistines in this regard it's there
all over the world to regard the you
know the sphere of the arts as being in
some way cult you know some way optional
it's the icing on the cake you know to
the meringue but the real cake is is the
sponge and you know that's underneath I
would I would you know I believe in a
much more organic and you know
organically knit kind of conception of
cultural activity than that and and the
the and I'm sorry that you know one of
the first things to go in the small
child when cuts have to be made is the
supposedly less important art classes
but that is just something that you know
one is dealing with and it's the same
all over the world in moments of
shrinking educational possibility
you know the visual literacy of
Americans you know or many Americans
compared to that and that you know they
almost complete visual indifference of
many French that I know is staggering
but you know you you know it's always
going to seem somehow optional and this
was one of the situations which the NEA
was set up to solve and on the whole I
think with the usual you know with all
the admitted sort of losses and
imperfections you know a nap right
wasted money in you know confusions and
controversies it has on the whole worked
out pretty well
[Music]
now anyone who what about artists who
are either so disaffected or
disinterested that they're not going to
make application to any agency upon
their ability to write the case of their
art yes because it's a better picture I
[Music]
don't know many artists who can't write
but the the I mean I suppose such may
exist the point is not that you find
them but that they find you I mean the
NEA is out there everybody knows it
exists and if the artist does not wish
to apply for the for an NEA grant that
is that artists absolute right as well
as it is his or her right to apply the
NEA is not a missionary Act institution
it's one which responds to applications
as I understand it or perhaps you feel
it should be a more missionary
institution
[Music]
[Music]
well in that case perhaps you should
streamline and simplify the process of
grant application I'm sorry I can
suggest no other alternative you can't
force that you can't force the cream to
the top the cream has to float of its
own molecular nature yes
which is we have a tremendous need to
understand the other side of the world
and the leaders as more conservative
concerned citizens most of our
immigrants from China
Oaxaca which took initiative to be a
self support organization and to provide
repairs our workshops
coincide with school education post
study elementary school middle school in
high school my question is as a national
federal support organization how do you
support initiative adversity
organization at us so high I myself and
several members with any success
you see unfortunately I can't help you
because I do not know the anything that
you know and will never apply for
granting them back and so I don't know
what the procedures were application to
well in that case I mean wouldn't it
possibly fall under the purview of the
National Humanities I just don't know I
I'm sorry
I think probably you know if you were to
ask somebody who is you know who
actually works within the NEA and works
within funding organizations you might
very well get an answer to that question
but I myself cannot supply it okay this
is the last one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I think that certainly the NEA has
come under fire because some of the I
mean obviously it's come under fire
because some of these material that it's
funded has been found morally offensive
by others that we take for granted and I
think that the you know if you were to
look through thee as where the funding
annals of the NEA you would find that
only a small number of grants and most
of those in fact in the 1980s rather
than the 70s caused any kind of
kerfuffle at all it does not make you
see I I have to say that I'm rather
opposed to this conventionalized
language of saying that things like
symphony concerts and dance concern and
so forth are safe culture I mean I don't
know first of all whether we you know
what sort of value we're supposed to
attach relatively to safe and unsafe
culture I mean I you know it seems to me
that the performance of say a a piece of
music by Hindu met or or Mozart or
whoever is not the result of it or not
to be classified in terms of either
safety or unsafety but rather in terms
of the you know the sort of aesthetic
pleasure and enlightenment that the
audience might get from them I mean the
idea that we that the NEA has to be
strung out between works of art which
are well nobody uses the word
avant-garde anymore but cutting edge and
those which are not and that it should
be supporting cutting edge stuff and
shouldn't be supporting the other I
think basically that's hokum I think you
know the-the-the because value does not
rise from anywhere else except deep
inside the work of art it doesn't rise
from primarily from you know it's
supposed power of social contestation
although that may have something to do
with it
it isn't the mandate
at the NEA to constantly fund works of
art which will notionally that all
points challenge the status quo the
status quo in America is enormous ly
tolerant the status quo is you know sort
of if you're talking about taste
includes just about everything and it's
opposite it is a big rubber war which it
is really hard to to make a permanent
dent in because America's institutional
culture for the last 70 years has been
nothing other than the new therefore the
the you know this is why I you know keep
you know saying that you know what the
NEA ought to be going for is you know
art which is you know you know sort of
trying to encourage work so but I've
rather upon the guesses that can make
about their aesthetic quality than their
capacity for social contestation now you
can have very good works of adding their
great works of art that are socially
[Music]
challenging of course you can always
have that but the idea that the NEA
should be looking out specifically for
works of art which are for instance
political rather than non political I
think is something of a distortion of
its mission if the now I'm not going to
get off on this because I've said it
before the the yeah gallery
well I think the only way was poleaxed
by the the what went on ladies it wasn't
expecting it didn't know how to deal
with it and it proved remarkably inept
at responding to it and of course the
you know there was a there was a sense
of disorientation and loss of direction
and loss of mission this I think you
know you know combined with the fact
that you know the man who was running it
at the time thrown Meyer was not the
captain will have wanted to have on the
ship when the typhoon hit sure I mean
the NEA has got a lot of ground to make
up
I mean the NEA has got to go back to
being a pretty tough organization
otherwise it's going to go down know
Here I am late in middle age not a
citizen I mean do you think that I've
got to spend the rest of my life buffing
horns with this bunch of dinosaurs and
meddling this is a job which nobody in
his right mind you know who has you know
who wants to write or paint or do
anything himself or would want to do
yeah I mean the person that I think you
know my candidate for the NEA would be
Jay would be John Brad amis but he can't
do it he doesn't want to do it I mean I
would really like to see you know him
proud of us would be superb in that job
but the the the it's a very it's a very
tough job and and and and the rewards
for it or not actually very high you
know you know their problem you create
one in great and twenty male context
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming I dare
say that not all of our panelists would
have agreed with everything that was
said tonight and I did resist the urge
sort of professorial urge to call on
them and say mr. consul what do you
think of that what you will hear
tomorrow if you come I hope you will all
be there and it does begin at 9:15 I
look forward to seeing you thank you and
thank you
[Applause]